i got a pretty cool one i got to get you
oh dude
yeah vitor beat the i know
i know that
who let somebody's grandpa fight dude he
threw down throwing a hook
i was like oh my god this is one of the
greats
he just slipped and fell through the
rope throwing a hook i thought about
that you're one of the greatest of all
time and father time father time comes
in and goes you are an old man now yeah
there's a reason for it though that's
right and everyone's like but with trt
and technology dude it does six boxing
isn't for 60 euros against vitor belfort
who's 44 but still
still a hell of an athlete yeah you know
what i'd like to say you know what i'm
going to say you know what i'm going to
say vitor logan paul jake not jake not
jake yeah that'd be a good fight huh
yeah that'd be a hell of a fight tough
fight for jake very tough fight for jake
it's it's tough to tell that's a
different thing right but it's tough to
tell where vitor is at like yeah anybody
in this room in here would have beat
offender not me i doubt i i would
backflip dude
he should not have been in there like it
was so clear like you said what i tell
you dude i went i did that chaired event
with him and i was like oh my god how's
this guy putting him he's got spared by
florida look at that oh gosh that's
awful poor guy that is awful
it's just not right man
oh jesus christ
jack i know
he looks great
oh no i don't like this at all
i don't like this man i don't like
seeing one of the greats
oh geez see but those aren't even like
crazy shots either
then the guy just had to oh yeah dj
khaled had to stop it and how about a
vander holyfield was mad at the stoppage
he's gotta ask this should have been
stopped six weeks ago
you shouldn't have been allowed
should have been stopped six weeks
it was tough to watch huh yeah yes
didn't you see your boy tito yeah that
was tough to watch what was weird is in
the
derrick bronson bike tito derek's on
food truck tomorrow by the way but uh
what's inside about that is we were
watching officer watch in the back and i
was like oh is this like a gentleman's
agreement because he was kind of like
half ass in it and then we at the angle
you couldn't really see anderson landed
flush and then we see like oh that is
not gentleman's agreement that was a
hard
shot
yeah and i think tito wants to fight
logan now is what he said so we're both
coming off losses
yeah i i don't like it i told you in
this one below the belt i've been a fan
of like this cross-pollination of
youtubers celebrities and fighting like
do what you want if you're making money
more power to you
the guys who are fighting these
youtubers getting their highest paydays
of all time i'm all for it this is the
when i not tito and anderson that's
whatever
that makes sense when the first time
i've been like oh we've gone too far is
when a vanner got in there yeah and fell
through the left hook at 60 i'm like
well what are we doing man dangerous now
it's just not it's dangerous it ruins
his legacy it's like what are we doing i
also i'm as a huge fan of of tito's
um and somebody who did so much for the
sport
i don't want to see him get hurt yeah
that's so bad for him at his age
that is so bad for him and 46 40 40 too
old because it's not just 44. you're
talking about a guy who's pushed his
body to such a limit yeah and fought so
much that when you take that kind of
damage and you know i don't know how
hard that shot was it looked really hard
but the one thing that that it seemed
seems to be happening a lot of guys is
that when you when you take enough
damage to the head because you got to
remember he's training probably with
boxers yeah you're getting so they're
full on your body will shut down earlier
i just hate seeing you you're talking
about the toughest dudes
in the world i hate seeing it yeah
because i i don't like seeing a great
warrior like tito
put in there anderson silva still got a
[ __ ] load of punch left that dude stud
one of the greatest strikers yeah well
one of them's passionate about boxing
and then you guys do it for a payday and
that's what happens there you go it was
tough that was a tough card to watch man
i don't think jake paul is is is gonna
wanna like i i think if they start
floating anderson silva's name out there
well logan and anderson were pretty
close to fighting before logan fought
floyd be a long that'd be a short night
for for logan i believe all due respect
yeah it would be tough that's i i don't
i would be very surprised if logan would
take that fight do you think he would
take that from he was going to
did he get talked out of it
uh no you got talked into floyd
mayweather for a 2 gallon dollars there
you go smaller much smaller guy yeah but
also much bigger fighters every bit is
tall yeah but anderson versus logan's
like you can make that money it does
well anything logan does does sure well
and amsterdam does well but not floyd
well that's right you're gonna make all
the money fighting a small guy yes and
not stupid not get hurt and i can get
knocked out we saw you know last the
round